اي مواجهه في الضفه الغربيه بين اسرائيل
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه بعد اعوام من
محاولات تجفيف المنابع وشبه اختفاء كامل
للعمل المسلح اعادت المقاومه في الضفه رسم
المشهد من جديد يمكن القول ان العمل
المسلح هناك ينقسم الى نوعين عمليات فرديه
واخرى جماعيه العمليات الفرديه ينفذها شخص
او اثنان ليس اكثر عاده ما تكون عمليات
طعن او اطلاق نار في مكان محدد تنتهي
بالاعتقال او القتل يحصل المنفذون على
اسلحتهم بطريقه شخصيه عبر شرائه من تجار
السلاح او قد يكون السلاح سكينا من المنزل
في النوع الثاني نتحدث عن الخلايا وتلك
اما تابعه لفصائل معروفه واجنحتها
العسكريه او تشكيلات عسكريه جديده كحاله
عرين الاسود التي لا ينتمي مقاتلوها الى
اي من الفصائل المعروفه ينفذ هؤلاء
المقاتلون عمليه اطلاق نار على النق
اخرى منها فلسطينيون الخط الاخضر او تجار
الاسلحه الاسرائيليون الذين لا يهمهم الا
المال بالدرجه الاساسيه لا تزال اسرائيل
تبحث في كل مره عن كل تفصيله تفيدها في
وقف هذا العمل لكنها على الارض تواجه
مقاومه لها اذرعها ووسائلها المختلفه لا
تخفي الفصائل الفلسطينيه وقوفها وراء كثير
من ذلك العمل بل تهدد بالمزيد تلك رساله
يكرر قاده في الفصائل التاكيد عليها وهي
الاعلان عن التنسيق المشترك للعمل المسلح
في الضفه الغربيه من هذه الرسائل ظهور
نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس صالح
العروري بلباس عسكري للمره الاولى مباشره
بعد ساعات من تهديد نتنياهو له بالاغتيال
متهما اياه بالوقوف وراء العمليات في
الضفه يقول العروري واخرون ان المرحله
الحاليه في الضفه الغربيه مختلفه تماما
عما جرى عليه الامر في السنوات الماضيه